Brooklyn nine-nine this is very exciting
a terrific show you're in what season is
it season yeah that's great yeah
exciting you're getting it the world
thanks.thanks season premiere yeah yeah
well I definitely you know would be
remiss if I didn't say I really need
everybody to tune in to the season
premiere last night at 9:30 you said
last night yeah you got to watch it last
night at 9:30 it was on right after the
mick please tune in okay so you're
telling us it was yesterday's episode
yeah how do you want people to watch
yesterday's episode
yeah well it's important to not watch it
you know like on Hulu or on-demand or
something because then you don't get to
see any of the commercials right so what
you want to do is watch it last night at
9:30 and how do you want people to watch
last night's episode I think kind of
however you feel is right I mean
probably the easiest is to just build a
time machine just go back and check that
out Andy who the hell knows how to make
a time machine well I do it's actually a
really easy Conan you see you first take
a nice hot bath with some fragrant bath
soaps and lots of candles you got a
de-stress then you get your hands on a
medium-sized blob of plutonium it's got
to be a blob not a kubera severe el blob
then stick the blob of plutonium in a
toaster oven set the toaster oven on low
like you're reheating a slice of
pepperoni pizza not mushroom pepperoni
then tie the toast drove into a kayak
when you tie the toaster down use a
crazy not like a sailor would use the
crazier than not the better so
time-travel can't figure out how to
untie it
time-travel is a wily [ __ ] then slather
yourself in green goop so you maintain
your size and shape during the
time-travel process I recommend
Stouffer's brand the same company that
makes frozen dinners and stuff like that
yeah you can find it the time travel
I'll get in the kayak and go to
RadioShack where the employees will ask
you to leave because you're all covered
in green goop and then you can sue them
for discrimination after you win a lot
of money in the discrimination lawsuit
you can use that money to buy a time
travel machine
then go back in time and watch last
night's episode of Brooklyn nine-nine
and those sweet sweet commercials
[Applause]
you